We are in the home stretch.
Problem number 17 on page 463.
Oh, I like these with these
strange operations.
Let the operation up arrow be
defined as a up arrow b is
equal to a plus b over a minus
b, for all numbers in a and b,
where a does not equal b.
And why do they to
have to say that?
Well, because otherwise, our
denominator would be 0.
So we know that 1 up 2 is equal
to 2 up x, what is x?
So let's set up the equation.
So what is 1 up arrow 2?
So that's 1 plus 2
over 1 minus 2.
So it's 1 plus 2
I just used this formula,
1 is a, 2 is be, right?
What's 2 up arrow x?
That's 2 plus x over
2 minus x.
So 1 plus 2 is 3.
1 minus 2 is negative 1.
So it's negative 1 is equal to
2 plus x over 2 minus x, and
of course this is just
equal to negative 3.
And now we can multiply both
sides of this equation by 2
minus x, because we know that x
can't be equal to 2, because
it says a can't be equal to b.
So we know we're not multiplying
both sides of this
equation by 0.
2 minus x.
That's all I'm doing, I'm
just multiplying both
sides by 2 minus x.
On the left-hand side, I
get negative 3 minus 3,
times 2 minus x.
And on the right-hand side, the
2 minus x's cancel out,
and I get 2 plus x.
And then I distribute the 3.
Minus 6 plus 3x is equal
to 2 plus x.
And let's see, where
do I want my x's?
Let's add 6 to both sides.
3x is equal to 8 plus x.
Subtract x from both sides.
2x is equal to 8.
x is equal to 4.
Choice A.
OK, problem number 18.
I'm going to switch colors, too,
because this color is not
appealing to me.
Let's see, green.
18, looks like this involves
money, so green is good.
During a sale, a customer can
buy one shirt for x dollars.
So 1 for x.
Each additional shirt
costs z dollars less
than the first shirt.
soon.
So additional z less than first.
For example, the cost
of the second shirt
is x minus z.
All right, fair enough.
Which of the following
represents the customer's cost
in dollars for n shirts bought
during the sale?
So the first shirt is
going to cost x.
The first shirt's
And then how many
shirts are left?
Well, there's n minus 1 shirts,
that aren't the first
shirt, right?
They buy 1 shirt at x and then
they're going to buy n minus 1
at the other price.
And then the other price
is x minus z.
Because it's not like the third
shirt costs z less than
the second, and then the fourth
shirt costs z less
than-- they all cost z less
than the first, right?
So every other shirt
costs x minus z.
So we have n minus
1 other shirts.
The first one costs x, then we
have n minus 1 shirts that
cost x minus z dollars.
And did they draw it
right like that?
Yes, that is choice A.
I thought maybe they might have
multiplied it out and
we'd have to look for something
similar, but they
give it just the way it is.
All right, next problem.
Problem number 19.
I don't need to draw
it neatly.
I can draw this thing
freehand.
OK, so this is P, 30
degrees, Q, and R.
In the figure above, QR is the
arc of a circle with center P.
If the length of QR is 6 pi,
what is the area of sector P?
So this length is 6 pi,
so they want to know
what this area is.
Well, the important realization
is is that this is
part of a larger circle.
So if I were to draw the entire
circle like that, and
then I would draw-- let me do
it in a different color.
This is part of a larger circle,
where this is P, Q, R,
and 30 degrees.
And this 30 degrees is important
because it tells us
what fraction of the larger
circle this is.
Well, how many degrees are there
in a total circle? you
Well there are 360, right?
If we were to go all the way
around, there's 360.
So the fraction that this is
of the full circle is 30
degrees over 360.
And this is 1/12.
I haven't drawn it to scale.
The way I drew it, it looks more
like 60 degrees, but you
should be able draw 12 pies
of 30 degrees here.
I hope I'm not confusing you,
because there are 360 degrees
in the circle.
So if this slice is 1/12 of the
whole circle, then this
arc length, this 6 pi right
here, is going to be 1/12 of
the entire circumference.
So what's the circumference?
The circumference is going
to be 12 times this.
So the circumference
is 12 times 6 pi,
which equals 72 pi.
If the circumference is 72
pi, what is the radius?
What's the formula?
Circumference is equal
to 2 pi r.
So we could say that also
is equal to 72 pi.
So you could divide both sides
by pi, and then divide both
sides by 2.
And you have the radius
is equal to 36.
So this radius right here-- let
me do it in a different
color-- this radius
is equal to 36.
All I did is I figured out this
arc length is 1/12 of the
entire circumference.
And so the entire circumference
is 72 pi.
And then I used that to
figure out that the
radius must be 36.
Now we want to know the area
of just this piece.
So we could just figure out the
area of the whole thing
and then divide by 12, because
this is 1/12 the area of the
circle as well.
So what's the area?
Area is equal to pi r squared.
That equals pi times 36
squared-- I'm going to write
36 times 36.
I don't want multiply
big numbers.
And then that's the area of the
whole thing, is pi times
36, times 36.
So the area of just this
fraction will be the area of
the whole thing divided by 12.
And the reason why I didn't
multiply it out is because I
can actually cancel.
I can say, well, this
is 3, this is 1.
So it's pi times 3, times 36.
And what's 3 times 36?
90 plus 18 is 108, so
it equals 108 pi,
which is choice A.
Let's see if I can squeeze
in the last problem.
Probably not.
Actually, I will save the last
problem for a video of its
own, because I only have
a minute left.
See